내 첫인상이 기억나니?
응.
진짜 껄렁껄렁 거리면서 왔어요.
야.
존나 떨었어 그때.
정신만 먹고 갔어.
아 진짜?
와가지고 이렇게 웰컴 라인 와가지고
아 와.
생일 축하해요.
이래서 내가 어?
어? 뭐 이런 걸까?
아 그냥 뭐.
야야.
거 머리를 씨멸 200번 돌리게
화장실에서 연습했어 거울 보면서.
이게 낫나?
아 이게 낫...
아 이게 낫겠다 해가지고
그런 거 한 거야.
아 진짜?
그르륵.
딱.
누구나 진솔한 대화만 나누게 되는
진의 전문 토크쇼
그르륵깍 딘딘입니다.
그르륵깍이 요즘 핫해요.
많은 분들이 또 이렇게 나와주시고
연락도 오고 해가지고
저희가 사실 아 이 친구는 한 번 모셔야 되지 않나
저랑 굉장히 친하고
동갑내기 친구들이 막 그렇게 많지 않은데
예.
좀 유일한...
유일한... 유일한가?
어 어쨌든.
초반 유튜브 할 때도 저에게 그래도 도움을 줬고
제 채널에
이미 영상에 올라가 있는 분인데
그것도 한 100만 찍었을 거예요.
한 번 모셔봤습니다.
어디 있어?
어떻게 들어가?
여기?
여기로 들어오는 거야.
아아.
오케이.
들어가시죠.
오늘 게스트 소유 씨입니다.
네 안녕하세요.
소유입니다.
반갑습니다.
아 살 많이 뺐네.
엄청 빠졌다가
다시 조금 쪘다가
지금 다시 조금 빼고 있어.
야 내가 본 거 중에 제일 말랐는데 지금?
그럴 수도 있겠다.
씨스타 때보다 많은 거 같은데?
이게 나이 먹어서 그런가 봐.
네.
저 친구고요.
친구고 이제 저기 뭐.
근데 네가 만약에 나를 전에 봤으면 너 나한테
너 어디 아파.
아 너무 말라서?
이랬을 거 같아.
너무 말라서?
응.
발리 갔다 오고 나서부터 진짜 엄청 운동했어 나 지금.
몸을 엄청 건강하게 만들었어.
어우 야 손이 많이 빠졌네.
아니 그냥.
아니 벗진 마.
벗는 게 아니라.
별로 보고 싶진 않아.
그냥 딱 여기가 그냥.
아 옷이 이렇게 남는다고?
그러니까 너 어디 아파?
뭐 하는 거 아니지?
약간 이랬을 거야.
그게 왜?
봐봐.
너 주변에.
근데 옷 좀 입으면 안 되냐?
거기 마이크가 차 있는.
아 맞아.
너 진짜 지금 나랑 편의점에 있다고 생각했구나.
일단 호유 씨를 모셨는데.
이거 봤어 너?
봤어.
그래 누구 거 봤어?
처음 딱 했었을 때.
오존?
어 오존 걸 봤어.
아 그거 실험작이었어.
실험작.
아 진짜 연예인을 안 부를 생각인가 보다.
오존 연예인이야.
아니야 아니야.
오존 연예인.
아니 처음에 유튜브 채널을 할 때
연예인들에 의존하는 채널을 만들고 싶지 않았어.
그리고 지난번에 나 원래 유튜브 했었잖아.
우리 술 먹던 것도 했고.
근데 그 이후로 막 뭔가 이 게스트 섭외도 너무 빡세고 하니까.
아 그런 게 있지.
어 그래서 아 그냥 나 혼자 할 수 있는 걸 좀 하자 하다가
근데 내가 그냥 나 진대하는 걸 워낙 좋아하니까
진짜 노가리 까는 걸로 하나 할까 하다가
오존을 이제 시험 삼아 했지.
응.
나쁘지 않더라?
어 재밌는 거야.
내가 나 혼자 재밌는 거야.
어 네가 진짜 즐거워 보였어.
어 왜냐면 카메라 놓고 훈수질하는 게 너무 재밌는 거야.
그러다가 여기저기서 이제 앨범 나올 때 연락이 오는 거야.
그래서 세훈이도 얼마 전에 왔다 갔고.
우리 요즘 핫해 야.
야 핫한 거 알지.
내한 오는 사람들이 막 우리 나오고 싶다고 막.
누구?
내한 오시는 분들이 막 우리 나오고 싶다고 막.
아 근데 일단 너가 영어가 잘 되니까.
그래가지고 지금 막 꽤 와.
근데 그래도 어쨌든 만사 제치고
소유 면은 사실 소유 먼저 해야지 해가지고 소유 씨 모셨습니다.
아니 앨범 나온다며?
언제 나와?
4월 29일.
4월 29일?
미니야?
미니야.
너 근데 이 회사 지금 옮긴 다음에
그리고 처음 나오는 거 아니잖아.
PDA가 나왔잖아.
그 다음 이제 미니가 나오는 거야.
PDA는 싱글이고.
PDA는 싱글이.
근데 너도 알겠지만 요즘 미니 내는 게 쉽지 않잖아.
아 쉽지 않아.
미니도 쉽지 않아.
그래서 진짜 내가 엄청 계속 계속 얘기를 했어.
내기 싫다고 아니면 미니를 내고 싶다고?
내고 싶다고.
근데 이제 힘든 부분들이 굉장히 많다 보니까.
사실 미니가 왜 쉽지 않다는 게 우리끼리는 아는데
이게 아마 보시는 분들은 왜 쉽지 않아 하실 텐데
미니에 들어가는 비용이
그치 그치.
그리고 이게 뭔가 아이돌처럼 고정 팬덤이 몇 십만 장을 팔아주지 않는 시스템이면
이게 사실 쉽지 않지.
쉽지 않지.
근데 뭔가 올해는 내가 뭔가 음악적으로 뭔가를 더 가져가고 싶다라는 게 되게 컸어.
그치.
그게 원래 너는 늘 있었는데
조금 뭔가 이렇게 공격적으로 너가 뭘 하기보다는 그냥 좀 기다리고 있는 상황이었는데
PDA 이후로 약간 뭔가 재미를 본 것 같더라고.
아니 그게 아니라 PDA가 나는 진짜 처음으로 내가 솔로를 하면서
아 나 못하겠다.
왜?
아 이 컨셉을 못하겠다?
아니 이 노래를.
아 이 노래를?
어 아 맞아 너가 원래 평소에 하던 건 아니니까.
그러니까 약간 너무 어려웠고 노래가.
아까 처음에는 그냥 와 노래 간지다 이랬는데.
듣긴 좋지.
근데 이거를 내가 부르면 이게 까딱 잘못하면 MG 느낌 내려고 하는.
이모 느낌 날까봐?
이모 느낌 날까봐.
내가.
개꺼나 잘 돼 있지 않아?
어 좋은데?
자기애까나 잘 돼 있지 않아?
고맙다.
내가 하고 싶은 말이었는데 야 너무 좋았다.
근데 이번에는 진짜 그냥 음악만 하자.
그럼 춤이 없어?
없어.
근데 그러면 예를 들어서 지금 아직 내가 노래 못 들어봤잖아.
약간 PDA 갬성이야?
아 노.
밴드셋의 R&B인데.
어.
아 그러면 사실 없어도 되지.
춤이.
근데 PDA는 내가 딱 처음에 듣고 어 좋은데?
그러다가 갑자기 뮤비를 너가 막 이렇게 티저를 올리는데 아 클릭하기가 겁나는 거야.
이게 잘못하면.
이게 잘못하면 자기애 쩌는 30대 누나가 MG를 하는 느낌이 난단 말이야.
그래서 내가 아 두려운데 하고 봤는데 어 생각보다 괜찮은 거야.
그래서 내가 살을 엄청 뺀 거야.
일단 내가 이제 많은 것들을 포기해야 됐어.
근데 내가 워낙 운동하는 것들을 너무 좋아하고 건강한 몸을 좋아하니까.
그래서 했는데.
그런데 살이 어느 정도에서 안 빠지는 거야.
아 이거 어떻게 해야 되냐 하다가 아 근육을 빼봐야겠다.
근데 근육을 빼니까 진짜 몸무게가.
쭉 떨어지지.
쭉 떨어지는 거야.
그리고 하염없이 떨어지는 거야.
그래서 내가 발리가 썼을 때 그냥 난 진짜 진짜 잘 먹고 했거든?
근데 48kg까지 빠진 거야.
너 원래 한 80.
뭐?
미안하다.
너무 갔다 야.
재미도 없고.
아 미안하다 좀.
야 80은 좀 너무 갔다.
사실 왜냐면.
70은 약간.
사람들이 어 그랬나 할 수도 있을 것 같아서 좀 더 뛰어봤지.
너 60까지는 찍지 않았었어?
한창 때?
아니야.
근육 이럴 때도 한 번 있었잖아.
나 68 찍고 충격 먹었어.
그래 봐봐 70.
야 봐.
2kg만 더 쪘으면 쉽지 않았어.
내가 말했잖아.
그래 내가 얘기했잖아.
68은 그럴싸해.
그래서 80으로 떠진 거야.
아니 여자한테는 68이라고 하면 다 충격 먹어.
너 68이었잖아.
그러니까 68을 찍고 내가 충격을 먹었다고.
그때 내가 봤을 때 얘가 그 정도 돼 보였었거든.
어.
아 그래?
어어.
난 그때.
난 몸무게를 안 쟤니까.
그냥 난 아주 건강한 상태라고 생각을 했어.
되게 건강했어 그때.
그때 되게 건강했어 너.
잠시만요.
소유랑 나랑 처음 만난 게 언제냐면.
아이씨 이거 개 웃긴 얘긴데.
2013년도에 얘 생일 파티였어.
아 맞아 맞아 맞아.
근데 나는 그때 쇼이더웨이 나온 지 얼마 안 됐어.
그래서 그냥 이 연예계가 되게 신기할 때고.
소유는 완전 최정상 아이돌일 때야.
근데 매드클라운 형이 이제 소유랑 착해 빠졌어를 했잖아.
그다음에 이제 얘가.
매드클라운 형 그래도 아 연예인 이제 된 거 같은데 한번 슬쩍 얼굴 비춰 보실래요 이러고 생일 파티에 놀러 오라고 한 거야.
내가 그런 멘트를 하진 않았어요.
아니 매드클라운이 되게 그런 느낌으로 받았대.
설렐 때.
아 진짜?
나 이 얘기는 처음 들어봐.
나도 이제 연예인들의 파티에 나도 참석을 하나 막 이렇게 되게 설레어 하다가.
그 형이 혼자 가긴 좀 민망하니까.
그 형이 되게 생각하는 연예인 같은 사람이 나였던 거야.
래퍼들 중에 내가 아는 애 중에 그래도 가도 좀 잘할 수 있을 것 같은 애가.
딘딘이다 해서 이제 나한테 연락이 와서.
같이 가자 이렇게 된 거야.
근데 나도 그때 뭐 쇼미더머니만 나왔지 연예인들이랑 뭘 한 적이 없잖아.
뭘 해야 되지?
뭔가 엄청 막 고급 샴페인 마실 것 같고 막 이러는데 뭐 해야 되지 하다가.
아 그럼 생일 파티니까 선물을 하나 가져와야겠다 해서.
향수를 하나 가져왔어.
니 그냥 받은 거 준 거잖아.
근데 이제.
근데 나는 명품 향수를 가져왔어.
맞아 맞아.
그리고 그게 아마 OMG였을 거야.
2층에 이렇게 있는데 그 메인 테이블 있어.
아니야 거기를 내가 다 통으로 대관을 했지.
근데 너는 모르겠지만.
넌 주인공이었으니까 모르겠지만.
너가 통 대관 했잖아.
근데 거기에서도 메인 테이블이 있었어.
아 그래?
그 왼쪽 그 바 쪽에 제일 가까운 여기 테이블에 이제 탑들이 다 앉아있고.
첨첨첨첨 밀리다가 나랑 매드클럽은 거의 개짜투리에 둘이 이러고 앉아가지고.
원래 이런 자리인가 봐 하고 있다가.
네가 와서 막 어어 막 이러고 같이 놀아요 하는데.
우리 둘 다 계속 보니까 막 못 놀겠는 거야 막.
아 그래서 얼마 안 있다가 바로 가지 않았어?
갔어 그리고 그날 비 왔거든.
개 웃긴 거 말해줄까?
그날 비 와서 압구정이었잖아.
이렇게 걸어서.
우리가 택시를 부르려고 하는데 비가 택시 안 잡히는 거 있어.
좀 걷자 하면서 비를 막 맞으면서 우리가 걸었어.
그다음에 거기 압구정 현대 옆에 파출소 있어.
근데 거기에 이렇게 지붕이 있으니까 파출소 앞에 이렇게 섰어.
비가 졸라 내리는 거야.
근데 우리 쫄딱 젖었어.
지금 탑스타 연예인 생일 파티를 갔다가 쫄딱 젖고 파출소 앞에 이렇게 서가지고 비를 피하고 있다가 매드클럽은 이러는 거야.
멜론 1위해도 변하는 게 없네 이러는 거야.
아 이거 개 웃긴 건데.
그렇게 만나고 나서 얘랑은 그냥 되게 금방 좀 빨리 친해진 것 같아.
내 첫 인상이 기억나니?
응.
그 너 생일 파티에서?
어.
진짜 껄렁껄렁거리면서 왔어요.
야 존나 떨었어 그때.
청심 안 먹고 있었어.
아 진짜 청심 안 먹고 있었어?
개 떨렸어 그때.
와가지고 이렇게 막 매드클럽에 와가지고 아 메리츠 가요.
막 이래서 내가 어?
어 왜 이런 걸까?
아 그냥.
야야.
그거 머리를 씨멸 200번 돌리게.
아 화장실에서 연습해서 거울 보면서 이게 낫나?
아 이게 낫, 아 이게 낫겠다 해가지고 그런 거 한 거야.
아 진짜?
그리고 근데 우리 테이블 가가지고 나랑 매드클럽이랑 형.
상대가 우리 괜찮았어 방금 막.
왜 이래.
너 좀 핫하대.
아니 우리가 컨셉이 어쨌든 편의점 약간 이런 건데.
너가 사실 편의점을 뭐 갈 일이 없잖아.
편의점?
당근.
얘는 거의 뭐 탄산수 사러 편의점 가지.
뭐 먹고 싶은 건 없잖아 사실.
그냥 이게 핫하다 그래도 갖고 온 거잖아.
어 맞아.
어 가져가 집에.
상대.
이거 누구, 누구랑 콜라보를 해 이거는?
아 니네 하이볼 지금 편의점 들어가 있지 않아?
있지.
우리 GS만.
어 그래?
와.
잘 나가 진짜.
저것도 얘 이거 오픈 준비할 때 얘가 하이볼에 미쳐있던 시즌이 있어.
그러니까 하이볼 웬만하면 그냥 시가 터서 먹는데 얘는 무슨 탄산 기계를 갖고 와가지고 막 조진다 해 막 이거 해서 막 야 먹어봐.
먹었어.
맛있네.
또 또 갑자기 야 이렇게 먹어봐.
계속 이러다가 하이볼을 할 거래 얘가.
근데 난 사실 연예인이 사업하는 거 있어서 그렇게 막 응원하는 타입은 아니니까 야 혹시나 하지 마라.
네 돈 많이 들어가면 하지 마라 이러는데.
엄청 이미 체계가 잡혀 있더라고.
그러고 했는데 결국 잘 됐잖아.
근데 약간 그냥 그거 난 진짜 음식으로 장난질 하지 말자여가지고.
맞아 맞아.
완전 고량주가 들어갔고 진짜 위스키가 들어갔기 때문에 이게 세금이랑 이게 엄청 많이 내기 때문에.
줄일세가 엄청나지.
근데 그때가 막 연예인들이 갑자기 술을 엄청 할 때야.
그래서 내가 야 근데 내가 다른 연예인들이 한 걸 먹어봤는데 좀 달고 사실 술 좋아하는 사람은 굳이 안 먹을 것 같다 그랬더니 얘가.
그래서 자기도 가오가 있으니까 진짜 술 좋아하는 사람들이 좋아할 만한 하이볼을 만들고 싶다 하면서.
그때 얘가 중국에서 갖고 온 그 고량주를 졸라 먹이는 거야 나한테.
내가 봤을 땐 실험지처럼 한 시간 동안.
야 이거 마셔.
이거 마셔.
어 야 나 돈 못 먹겠는데?
내가 갑자기 일어나더니 야 일어나니까 좀 운다.
어 그러고 내가 그러고 취한 상태로 간 거야 그냥.
잘했지.
잘했어.
그래서 요즘 뭐하고 살아?
진짜.
정신 없어?
하루가 어떻게 흘러가는지 모르겠다.
약간 이런 느낌?
지금 근데 뭐 녹음해야 되고 앨범 준비하느라 뭐 정신 없겠지 사실.
그리고 나도 이번에 유튜브 팀이 아예 싹 다 바뀌었어.
새로운 느낌의 뉴 버전의 소유기를 이제 시작하고 있어.
너 유튜브 언제 만들었어?
내가 먼저 했지?
내가 먼저 할걸?
아닌데? 내가 먼저 만들어서 너가 유튜브 이제 시작한다고 막 이랬었던 거 같은데?
언제야?
5년 전.
2020년.
난 언제야?
아 비슷하네.
소유랑 나랑 그 술 먹은 거 몇 나왔어?
90만? 어 100만 안 나왔네?
아 내 게 100만이 넘었어.
아 두 개로 찍었지?
아 맞아 맞아.
야 술 먹방 내가 원조야.
맞아.
내가 원조야 그때 왜 내가 저걸 했냐면 바쁘니까 술을 못 먹는 거야.
그래서 술을 먹고 싶은데 어떻게 먹어야 될까?
아 그럼 촬영 스케줄을 빼서 먹자 이렇게 된 거야.
그래서 유튜브를 술 먹는 걸 하자 이렇게 된 거야.
그래서 그때는 막 인식이 막 뭐 술을 뭐 조장하네 이런 것도 아니었어.
그냥 아무도 관심 없었어.
그래서 술을 졸라 먹었는데 문제가 우리가 술을 먹으면 뭐 12시간을 먹는데 카메라가 있으니까 짧게 먹어야 되는 거야.
어 그게 어 맞아 맞아.
그래서 저 원소주 찍을 때 2시간 동안 원소주 4병 깠나 이래.
그 다음에 진짜 맛탱이가 둘 다 가가지고 막.
근데 너는 나는 궁금한 게 그거야.
나는 이제 살면서 우리 술 먹으면 진짜 졸라 먹었잖아.
내가 낮술을 얘 때문에 아마 처음 했을 거야.
얘는 날이 좋으면 갑자기 전화 와.
뭐 하냐 이러면 어 나 지금 이제 나 이제 1박 끝나고 왔는데 그럼 마셔야지 이러면.
야 날 개 좋아 이러면서 그때 처음 먹고 이 행복을 안 거야.
낮에 취해서 이 약간 이 해 떠 있는데 나 혼자 정신 나가 있는데.
날씨 좋으니까 기분 좋고 약간 이게.
어 그러고 일찍 자고 다음날 생활이 가능하잖아.
지랄하지 마 그러고 새벽 5시까지 처럼.
어 그래 낮술 먹으면 빨리 끝나겠다.
아니 낮술 먹으면 더 길게 맞아.
너무 힘들어 막 저녁 되면은 막.
또 하나 기억나는 게 그때 낮이었어.
나 1박 2일 끝나고 딱 집에 와서 아 졸라 피곤하다고 이렇게 씻고 나왔는데.
갑자기 전화와서 어디야 이래서.
어 나 지금 1박 끝나고 집에 왔어.
근데 나와 이래서 못 나가 힘들어 그때.
그럼 우리가 갈게 하더니.
소유랑 진훈이랑 니콜이랑 셋이.
수박이.
수박이랑 막 사서 온 거야.
아 난 그래서 우리는 1박 2일 하고 왔다고 하니까.
진훈이랑 야 그럼 우리가 전복 같은 거 사가지고 얘 몸보신 좀 하게 요리 좀 해주자 이러고.
막 좋은 거 사간다 다 죄다.
나 이거 안 먹어 나 이거 알레르기 있어 나 이거 안 돼 막 이래갖고.
야 몸보신을 시켜줄 애가 소주를 진짜.
구라 안 치고 진훈이가 그 몸 좋은 애가 소주를 양손에 봉다리를.
이러면서 들고 막.
째랭 째랭 째랭 째랭 하면서 들고 갑자기 뒤에서 또 소주를 얘가 째랭 째랭 하면서 들어오는데.
내 냉장고에 소주를 갑자기 무슨 펜션 온 것마냥 막 넣는 거야.
그때 소주를 진짜 구라 안 치고 한 20병을 넘게 꽂아넣는 거야 그래서 내가 너희 미친놈들이 있냐 했는데.
아 심지어 그 날 진훈이랑 저랑은 이미 강간에서 먹다가 갔어요 낮술로.
지들끼리 신나가지고 펜션 온 애들마냥 우리 집에서 막 야 너 피곤하니까 전복 버터구이 해줄게 하면서 막 전복하는데 내가.
전복 알레르기 있다고 그랬나?
아니야 나 전복은 좋아하는데.
아니.
그러다가 진짜 계속 먹는 거야.
그러다가 이제 막 먹다가 내가 아마 쓰러졌을 거야 그래서 내가 먼저 자고 다음날 일어났는데 집이 깨끗해 아무도 없어.
꿈꾼 것 같은 거야.
그리고 냉장고를 열어봤는데 소주가 없어 그래서.
근데 병도 집에 아무 병도 없는 거야 그래서 어 시X 꿈꾼다?
이게 뭐지 근데 사진 보니까 막 어 분명히 뭐 먹었던 기억이 있는데 이게 어떻게 된 거지 했는데 얘네가 다 먹고 다 치우고 그냥 간 거야.
아니야 그러고 이제 3차로 우리 집으로.
그래 그래.
근데 너도 이제 이미지가 좀 세고 술 좋아하고 막 운동 좋아하고 약간 이런 게 있는데 그냥 그런 거를 바꾸고 싶은 생각은 없어?
나는 세다라는 말이 좀 상처였거든?
응.
왜냐면 너도 알잖아.
생각 나 말을 잘 못하잖아.
어 맞아 얘네는 사실 지가 답답하거나 짜증나는 부분이 있을 때 어필을 잘 못하지.
그냥 혼자 울어요.
그러니까 나는 그전에는 항상 그냥 회사에서 뭘 시키면 그냥 항상 내야.
왜냐면 결국 감정 소비를 하고.
기분 안 좋은 상태로 그 스케줄에 와서 하기 싫은 스케줄인데 왔어.
그렇게 되는 게 싫으니까 그냥 하는 거지 뭐.
지금은?
지금은 그래도 좀 말을 하지.
아니 회사를 소유가 이제 스타쉽에서 딱 끝날 때 이제 얘가 고민이 엄청 있어서 그때 제일 이야기를 많이 했지.
맞아 맞아 맞아.
얘기하면서 나는 사실 너가 여기 있었으면 좋겠다.
스타쉽에 계속 있었으면 좋겠다.
맞아 맞아.
난 그냥 너가 케이윌 형처럼 약간 여기에 아빠 엄마 같은 느낌으로 있으면 좋겠다.
회사에서도 어쨌든 너를 그 최고참인데 홀대하진 않을 거고 계속 있었으면 좋겠다 했는데 내가 여기에만 있었으니 다른 걸 좀 해보고 싶어 이래서?
아니 그것도 있었고 스타쉽에 있었을 때는 그게 있었어.
쉬는 게 안 됐어.
왜냐면 데뷔하고 나는 재계약까지 했잖아.
한 12년 동안 한 번도 제대로 쉬어본 적이 없는 거야.
그래서 내가 말했던 거 저 3개월만 딱 쉬게 해주시면 안 돼요? 라고 했었어.
뭐 유학 같이 뭐 내가 해외를 가든.
아니 미국 가서 음악 공부를 하든.
근데 절대 안 된다.
그래서 그거 절대 안 돼.
그러니까 그때는 약간 사장님의 마인드가 연예인이 2주 이상 쉬다 보면 일 안 하고 싶어진다.
미쳐진다.
일을 안 하고 싶어진다.
근데 나는 아니거든.
쉬면서도 일에 대한 생각을 엄청 많이 하는데 근데 나는 요즘에 그냥 서른의 나를 딱 보면 1년에 한 번씩 내가 한 달 살이로 어딘가를 가잖아.
맞아 맞아 맞아.
그게 그냥 일을 막 하면서도 힘들다.
아니야 지현아 너 이렇게 열심히 돈 벌어서 너 한 달 가서 거기서 쉬는 거야.
그리고 막 하다가도 이제 곧 있으면 여행 갈 수 있어.
맞아 맞아 그게 있지.
그러니까 이런 동기가 있다 보니까 그냥 달릴 때는 그냥 말처럼 그냥 막 달리고.
근데 그것도 어떻게 보면 네가 12년 동안 안 쉬고 일을 했기 때문에 이렇게 그래도 아 이제 한 달 가서 좀 있다가 다시 와서 활동하고 이게 되지.
아무튼 그래서 이제 그러고 난 다음에 이제 회사 옮기고 또 이번 회사 올 때도.
나는 소유한테 늘 얘기했던 게 야 너 그냥 발라드 하고.
맨날 나한테.
너 제발 춤 좀 추지 마라 그것 좀.
왜 자꾸 춤을 추냐.
너 이제 그냥 편하게 ost 하고 발라드 하고 하면서 그냥 보컬로 그냥 하면 되지.
왜 자꾸 춤을 추려고 그러냐고 그랬더니 아니래 퍼포먼스가 있어야 된대.
그러니까 이게 발라드 하면 나도 좋지.
근데 발라드를 또 하잖아 무대에서.
그럼 다른 사람 춤추는 거 보면 막 춤추고 싶어.
그럼 또 춤을 출 때는 발라드 가수들이 부러워.
그래 그래.
그런 것들이 있고.
그리고 뭔가 나도 내 정체성을 모르겠는 거야.
나는 뭐지?
나는 뭘까?
아직까지 난 아이돌일까?
나는 가수인 건가?
솔로 아티스트인 건가?
내 장르는 나의 주 장르는 뭐지?
약간 이러면서.
지금 부캐가 떠올랐어.
뭐?
엠지 이모 어떠냐?
엠지 이모.
그러니까 우리가 엠지인데?
안녕하세요.
저 엠지 이모예요.
약간 이런 느낌.
엠지 이모는 아니야.
근데 그렇다고 완전 엠지는 또 아니야?
근데 그러면 자.
앨범이 나와.
그러면 너는 뭘 하고 싶은 거야?
이제 앞으로.
너의 이제 나의 목표.
아니 뭔가 지금 이걸로 계속 하겠다는 게 아니라
앨범을 만들 때 Y가 붙잖아.
그리고 reason이 필요하고.
그러니까 뭔가 콘서트를 하기 위해서 이 앨범을 만들어야 된다.
약간 이런 마인드야.
아니 네가 얘기한 게 뭐냐면
아까 나는 어떤 정체성을 가진 가수일까?
이런 이야기를 했잖아.
근데 사실 내가 볼 때는 정체성 갖고 활동하는 사람은 정말 많지 않거든?
아 그래?
내가 볼 때는?
근데 갑자기 생각난 게 내가 너의 여태까지 변천사 이렇게 쭉 봐왔을 때
너는 씨스타로 활동을 했었고 솔로 가수로도 활동을 계속 하고 있고
그러면 할 게 너무 많은 거야.
그래서 콘서트를 만약에 예를 들면 발라드 가수인가 댄스 가수인가가 뭐가 중요하냐 이거지.
1부 섹션이랑 2부 섹션만 나눠도 색을 아예 다르게 갈 수 있어.
2부 섹션을 가져가기도 다채롭고 너무 좋은 콘텐츠잖아.
아니 근데 이게 또 그렇지가 않아.
왜 왜?
노래도 너무 많고 하고 싶은 노래는 너무 많은데 그 안에서 또 뽑아야 되고.
아 근데 생각보다 너의 공연을 보러 오는 사람들이 평론가처럼 오지 않잖아.
나는 근데 알잖아.
난 되게 뭘 하나 딱 하면 생각이 너무 많으니까.
1부에 네가 딱 1부 오프닝부터 네가 하고 싶은 지금 최근 것들을 쫙 하고.
2부 시작할 때쯤에.
이제 그 노래들로 송으로 쭉 풀다가 이제 마무리 쯤에 어쨌든 분위기 좀 신나게 이렇게 띄우고 보내주는 걸로 해가지고
시스터 메들리 조지고 빵 하면 되지.
그건 너무 그냥.
뻔하지.
뻔하잖아.
근데 사람들이 너의 모든 걸 보고 싶어 하면은 그런 게 좋지 않을까?
그래서 내가 일단 노래를 들려줄게.
근데 이게 지금 내가 녹음이 안 돼서 가이드가 없어.
근데 원래 이거를 선싱글로 하려다가 아무리 들어도 듣고 들어도 너무 좋은 거야.
그래서 이거를 타이틀로 가자.
아 오케이.
딱 이걸.
좋네.
이걸 딱 듣고 와.
근데 약간 빡친다.
왜?
너의 킹받는 표정이 나올 것 같아.
딱 저기서 딱 싸비 들어갈 때 플레이 할 때 너가 약간 막 약간 이렇게 갑자기 마이크 스테이지.
약간 이런 표정 지을 것 같은 게 갑자기 머릿속에 그려졌어.
아니야.
아니야 아니야?
난 약간 그런 느낌 아니야.
완전 이거는 진짜 내가.
그러니까 오히려 이번에 가사도 약간 어 나 쿨하지 않아.
그래서 나는 쿨한 거야.
약간 이런 느낌.
이거.
완전 이거는 진짜 멋있게 하고 싶어.
너무 멋있는 여자이고 싶어.
뭐라 해야 되지.
그러니까 서른이라는 나이가.
서른 여섯.
그러니까.
정말.
여섯 살이나 주는 건 좀.
아니 서른이라는 나이가.
이제 여자가 서른이 되면 막 사람들이 막 되게 막 서른되면 아줌마다.
막 이런 말들 하잖아.
에이 서른이 어떻게 아줌마야.
그러니까.
30대 라고 할게.
그래.
30대라고 할게.
그랬을 때 나는 어 그렇지 않은데.
라는 거를 조금.
그러니까 나는 그냥 내 나이 때 사람들이 봤을 때.
아 저렇게 늙고 싶다라고 하는 그런 멋있는 여성이고 싶어.
약간 지금은.
이제 너는 약간 우리 또래들.
그리고 한 20대 후반 친구들도 나도 나이 먹으면 저 언니처럼 되고 싶다.
약간 좀 멋있게 늙어가고 싶은 언니가 되고 싶다.
MC 이모 개짱이잖아.
딱 그 느낌이라니까.
애들이 보면서 와 저 누나는 진짜 개 멋있네 이거잖아.
저 언니 개 쿨하다.
저 언니처럼 나도 열심히 살고 싶다.
약간.
언니랑 이모랑 느낌이 좀 다르잖아.
MC 언니였대.
MC 이모가 웃기긴 해.
그래.
웃겨.
그래서 그래.
웃기긴 한데.
나도 지금 미안한데 계속 그게 꽂혀가지고.
아 혹시 오해하실 거예요.
뭐가.
이거는 그냥 이렇게 귀에 붙이는 침 같은 거예요.
아 저거 그거야.
그 부기 빼주는 거.
아 근데 그게 아니라 이거를 전문으로 하는 데가 있어.
용산에?
어.
어 알아 알아.
그거.
그럼 이 정도면 또 나중에 또 막 성형설 막 또 이런 얘기 나올까봐.
미리 말씀드리는 겁니다.
야 근데 그거 효과 있냐?
근데 이게 하고 나서 붙는 느낌은 잘 안 나 확실히.
말도 안 되는데 했는데.
일단 나도 한번 정보 좀 줘봐라.
나 이런 거 되게 좋아하거든 건강 관련된 거.
그래서 나 사실.
이상하게 얘는 잘 안 보는데 얘한테 되게 고마울 일이 항상 뭐가 생겨.
그래.
야 이거는 진짜.
야 이거는.
그거는 선물 받아야 돼, 진짜.
일단 첫 번째 얘한테 살면서 고마웠던 게
아는 형님을 나가는데
아이브 노래를 제가 해야 되는데
얘랑 갔다가 그냥 기타해서 그냥 해, 이랬다가
기타? 근데 좀 너무 오버 아닐까?
야, 기타해서 좋아, 이랬고
했는데 그게 조회수가 진짜 엄청 잘 나온 거예요.
그거랑 작년에
근데 제가 인터넷에 엄청 뜨는 거
노란 색깔 통 안에 들었는데 얘가 그걸 갖더라고요.
그래서 야, 이거 좋아, 이랬더니
아 몰라, 나도 그냥 긴가민가해서 받아보고 있어, 이랬고
제가 갔어요, 딘딘이 소개로.
내가 소개해줬어.
얘가 그 업체를 나한테 갑자기 DM으로
야, 이거 효과 있냐, 이랬어.
뭐 해봤는데 긴가민가한데 좀 더 해보려고 했는데
땀은 많이 나가지고 기분은 좋던데, 이랬더니
이제 소개시켜줘, 이랬어.
소개시켜줘서 얘가 간 거야.
근데 그러고 나서 제가 유튜브에서 다이어트할 때
실제로 내돈내산으로 했던 관리들 이렇게 해서 했는데
칼로리바 대표님이 그렇게 해주셔서 너무 감사하다
이제 얘기를 해줘서 아니에요, 이렇게 얘기하다가
모델이 된 거지.
그래.
광고 모델 됐어.
시향, 나는!
나는!
어쨌든.
아, 그거, 이거.
뭐야?
아니, 나 이거 게스트를 나오면 그래도
나도 술을 좋아하니까
이 사람한테 뭘 줘야 될까, 뭐 이러다가
술을 그 사람한테 좀 맞을 만한 걸 준비를 해.
왜?
그냥 선물이야.
그래서 돈 많이 써, 이제 안 하고 싶다고.
나 그런 걸 왜 해.
아니, 근데 처음에 한 거야.
왜냐면 우리가 이게 출연료가 막 나가는 게 아니잖아.
아니, 근데 뭐 서로 다 알고 하는 건데 그걸 너가 왜 술을 막 그렇게.
근데 이거야, 봐봐.
오존이 처음 나왔을 때는 이거를 만든 게 오존이 회사에서 연락이 온 거야.
우리 유튜브에 출연을 하고 싶다.
얘를 부르자 해서 불렀는데 출연료가 없어.
그냥 이렇게 터는 거야.
그러니까 미안한 거야.
그래서 샴페인을 하나 줬어.
몰래 뒤로 줘야지.
카메라 말고.
이게 지금 오해인가?
오해해서 이제 선물 그만 줄까?
어, 그러면 내가 이렇게 할게.
안 받을게, 내가.
아니, 받아야 돼, 근데.
샀어.
너가 하이볼 좋아하니까.
안 받고 나 그다음부터 주지 마.
나도 안 받을게.
너도 알겠지만 나는 하쿠슈에다가 하이볼 타 먹는 거 좋아해가지고.
아니야, 진짜.
아니야, 받아. 이미 뭐 샀는데 뭐.
아니면 이거 다른 사람 줘.
아니야, 가져. 선물이야.
고생했으니까 가끔 먹어라.
아니면 나중에 같이 먹자.
아, 뭘 부담스러워.
아, 그러니까 막 뭔가 술이 부담스럽다라기보다는
네가 걱정돼, 이제 앞으로.
아니, 그래서 오후에 이후로 이제 그만 하려고.
그거를 말을 해, 완벽하게.
아, 안 돼. 해야 돼.
감사합니다.
아, 이거 비싼 거를.
아무튼 그거야, 이제 뭐.
편의점에서 먹다 보면 막, 야, 해 떴다 이러잖아.
근데 우리 엔딩이 지금 해 떴다 가사인데
지금 해 졌으니까.
해 졌으니까 가자.
2차 가자, 2차.
네?
아, 이거 네 거구나.
아이, 재밌네.